في المرة الأولى التي أجرت فيها CNN مقابلة مع
عضو سابق في قوات الأمن الصينية ،
أخبر CNN أنه تلقى أوامر بشكل روتيني
باعتقال وتعذيب معتقلي الأويغور
بطرق مروعة وبربرية حقًا ،
تنفي الصين اتهامات الولايات المتحدة
التي اعتقلت ما يصل إلى
مليوني إيغور كثير منهم.  المسلم في
نظام معسكرات الاعتقال الحديثة في
منطقة شينجيانغ في شمال غرب
الصين يجلب لنا إيفان واتسون من سي إن إن هذه
الاكتشافات الجديدة المزعجة
ونريد تحذير مشاهدينا من أنها تحتوي على
أوصاف مصورة للعنف
والاعتداء الجنسي
أنها لمست العصا الكهربائية
هنا وهي  تمامًا مثل الحرق ،
هذه هي قصة ضحية
ومعذب اعترف بنفسه ، هل
استخدم ضباط الشرطة الهراوات الكهربائية لصدمة
السجناء ،
نعم نعم ، يستخدم الجميع طرقًا مختلفة
لسنوات من الاعتقالات التعسفية التي
لا توصف ، وكانت معسكرات الاعتقال الجماعي
تتدفق من  شهادات
منطقة شينجيانغ الصينية
من أشخاص مثل
عبد الله أيوب عندما تقوم بذلك  تم اعتقالك في عام 2013 ، ما
هي وظيفتك الرئيسية ، معلمة روضة أطفال ،
عبد الولي ، تقول إن الشرطة أخذته من
روضة الأطفال التي تعمل بلغة الأويغور ،
ووضعوا غطاء رأس أسود على وجهي
ووضعوني في غرفة الاستجواب هذه
، وداخل القفص المفارقة ، يوجد
كرسي نمر
يشبهك  مكبلة معصمك هناك
وقدميك المقيدة أيضًا ، كما يقول ، قال إن الشرطة
اتهمته بالتخطيط للتجسس
ضد الحكومة الصينية
وجريمة الانفصال وطالبوا
باعتراف ، فأنت تعترف فقط
بأنك اعترفت فقط بما فعلته ، فهذا جيد بالنسبة
لك
الآن لأول مرة.  لقد تحدثت CNN
إلى ضابط شرطة صيني
سابق يدعي أن وظيفته كانت اعتقال
وانتزاع اعترافات من
الأويغور العرقيين في شينجيانغ ، وكان
بعض رجال الشرطة يلعبون دور رجال الشرطة الطيبين
والبعض سيلعبون دور رجال الشرطة السيئين بعد
أن نضربهم ، سنعرض عليهم سيجارة
هل كان عليك أن تكون الشرطي السيئ في بعض الأحيان
بالطبع ، يقول الرجل الذي يطلب أن يُدعى تشانغ
إنه عمل أكثر من 10 سنوات كشرطي
قبل أن يفر من الصين
خيبة أمل متزايدة من الحزب الشيوعي الحاكم ،
التقيت به في دولة أوروبية ، كان
يرتدي زي الشرطة الخاص به لتوثيق
قصته لكنه لا يريد الكشف عن
هويته لحماية نفسه
وأقاربه الذين ما زالوا في الصين
لإثبات أنه كان ضابط شرطة صيني
يعرض لي جانج العديد
من الصور لشهادات تدريب مختلفة لشارات الشرطة
حتى
صور لفصل تخرجه في
أكاديمية الشرطة ،
صور لا يمكننا عرضها على التلفزيون
لأنهم سيكشفون عن
هويته.يقول تشانغ أنه تم إرساله من مقاطعته الأصلية
للعمل في شينجيانغ على الأقل
ثلاثة  عدد المرات التي أُمر
فيها باعتقال مئات المشتبه بهم جميعهم من
عرقية الأويغور ، فكيف تم
الاستجواب
بضربهم وضربهم
بالكدمات والمتورمة ، وطرقوا رؤوسهم
على المبرد.
يقول بعض المشتبه بهم لا تتجاوز
أعمارهم 14 عامًا وجميع المعتقلين تعرضوا
للضرب وكان المشتبه بهم جميعهم
رجال  ونساء هل شاهدت
نساء يتعرضن للضرب
نعم
cnn لا يمكن أن تؤكد بشكل مستقل
مزاعم تشانغ ولا عبدوالي
معلمة روضة الأطفال التي تقول
بالإضافة إلى الضرب أنه تعرض للاغتصاب في
الليلة الأولى من اعتقاله من قبل
سجناء صينيين اتبعوا أوامر
حراس السجن ،
كان هؤلاء سجناء.
من اعتدوا عليك جنسياً ، نعم ،
السجناء
أكثر من واحد أكثر من واحد ، نعم ، مثل
أولاً وقبل كل شيء أحاطوا بي
وأمرني رجال الشرطة هناك
بخلع ملابسي الداخلية وتركني
والانحناء أكثر من الانحناء
لا تفعل  هذا لا تفعل هذا. صرخ من
فضلك لا تفعل هذا
ثم مثل
أحد لا أعرف فقط أمسك يدي
مثل هذا
زانغ ، يصف ضابط الشرطة الذي فر من الصين
بالتفصيل طرق
التعذيب الجنسي التي يقولها ضباط الشرطة
إذا كنت تريد أن يعترف الأشخاص بأنك
تستخدم العصا الكهربائية ،
فسنربط سلكين كهربائيين على الأطراف ونضع
الأسلاك على أعضائهم التناسلية بينما
يتم ربط الشخص بالنتيجة  من الأفضل أن يقول أيضًا
إن الشرطة أمرت أحيانًا السجناء
بالاعتداء الجنسي على المعتقلين
نسميها تحقيقًا في السجن
، وتصر الحكومة الصينية على أنها
تحارب التطرف العنيف في شينجيانغ ،
وتنفي بكين أيضًا أي انتهاكات لحقوق
الإنسان تُرتكب
هناك ، لكن تشانغ يقول الشرطي المُبلغ عن المخالفات
لقد حصل على ضعف راتبه العادي
للانضمام إلى عشرات الآلاف من أفراد الشرطة الآخرين الذين تم
إرسالهم إلى شينجيانغ كجزء من
حملة الحكومة ،
كم عدد الأشخاص
الذين اعتقلتهم في شينجيانغ ، هل
تعتقد
أنهم كانوا في الواقع
متطرفين عنيفين
وهؤلاء الأشخاص هم مواطنونا
وليسوا أعداء أجانب  إذا
لم تقم بتنفيذ الاعتقال ، فماذا
سيحدث لك ،
فسيتم اعتقالي أيضًا لأن
هذا يعني أنني أيضًا جزء من
منظمة إرهابية ، فأنا
عدوهم عبد الوالي يقول بعد 15 شهرًا في
الاعتقال إنه اعترف
بجمع الأموال بشكل غير قانوني و  أُطلق سراحه ،
فر في وقت لاحق من الصين
منذ ذلك الحين ، ويقول إن العديد من
أقاربه قد اعتقلوا بما في ذلك  ng
ابنة أخته مهاري
حيث كانت ابنة أختك
في نفس
مرفق الاحتجاز الذي مكثت فيه.
مثل ابنتي
رداً على أسئلة مكتوبة من
CNN ، تنفي حكومة
شينجيانغ وفاة ميراي في الحجز
قائلة إن المرأة البالغة من العمر 30 عامًا
ماتت بسبب فشل في الأعضاء بسبب
فقر الدم الحاد بعد أن عولجت في المستشفى
بعد معاناتها من مرض مجهول
فعلته الحكومة الصينية  عدم الرد
على الأسئلة المكتوبة المتعلقة
بادعاءات ضابط الشرطة السابق
عبد الولي الذي يعيش الآن في النرويج مع
عائلته وينشر كتب أطفال
مكتوبة بلغة الأويغور
يصر على أنه يستطيع مسامحة الرجال الذين
سجنوه وعذبوه ، فأنا لا أكرههم
لأنهم جميعًا
ضحية لهذا النظام
إذا قابلت أحد هؤلاء السجناء ،
فماذا ستقول لهم
أنا خائف من أن أغادر على الفور
لماذا
كيف أواجه هؤلاء الأشخاص ستشعر بالضيق؟
مذنب حتى لو كنت مجرد جندي
فأنت لا تزال مسؤولاً عما
حدث نعم تحتاج إلى تنفيذ الأوامر
ولكن الكثير من الناس فعلوا هذا الشيء
معًا
فنحن مسؤولون عن ذلك